The following is a conversation
with Leslie Kale bling.
She's a roboticist and professor at Mit.
She's recognized for her work
and reinforcement learning,
planning robot navigation and
several other topics in AI.
She won the Edge Chi computers and thought
award and was the editor and chief of
the prestigious journal
machine learning research.
This conversation is part of
the artificial intelligence
podcasts at MIT and
beyond.
If you enjoy subscribe on Youtube,
iTunes or simply connect with
me on Twitter at Lex Friedman,
spelled f, r I. D.
And now here's my conversation
with Leslie Kale. Blaine.
What made me get excited about Ai,
I can say that is I read girdle Escher,
Bach when I was in high school.
That was pretty formative
for me because it exposed a,
the interesting ness of primitives and
combination and how you can make complex
things out of simple parts and ideas
of AI and what kinds of programs might
generate an intelligent behavior.
So,
so you first fell in love with
AI reasoning, logic versus robot.
Yeah, the robots came
because, um, my first job,
so I finished an undergraduate degree in
philosophy at Stanford and was about to
finish a master's in computer
science. And I got hired at Sri, uh,
in their AI lab and they
were building a robot.
It was a kind of a follow on to shaky,
but all the shaky people
were not there anymore.
And so my job was to try to get this robot
to do stuff and that's really kind of
what got me interested in robots.
So maybe taking a small step back,
your bachelors,
Stanford Philosophy did Master's
and phd in computer science,
but the bachelor's in philosophy as a,
what was that journey like?
What elements of philosophy do you
think you bring to your work in computer
science?
So it's surprisingly relevant.
So the part of the reason that I didn't
do a computer science undergraduate
degree was that there wasn't
one at Stanford at the time,
but that there's part of philosophy and
in fact Stanford has a special sub major
in something called now symbolic systems,
which is logic model theory,
formal semantics of national language.
And so that's actually a perfect
preparation for working in AI and computer
science
that this is kind of interesting.
So if you were interested
in artificial intelligence,
yeah.
The what, what kind of majors, where
people even thinking about taking,
what does it in neuroscience was?
So besides philosophies, what,
what were you supposed to do if you're
fascinated by the idea of creating
intelligence,
there weren't enough people who did that
for that even to be at conversation.
I mean,
I think probably probably philosophy.
I mean it's interesting in my class,
my graduating class of
undergraduate philosophers,
probably maybe slightly less than half
way done and computer science slightly
less than half went in law and like
one or two we're not in philosophy.
Uh,
so it was a common kind of connection.
Do you think AI researchers have a role,
be part time philosophers or should
they stick to the solid science and
engineering without sort of taking
the philosophizing tangents? I mean,
you work with robots, you think about what
it takes to create intelligent beings.
Uh, aren't you the perfect person to
think about the big picture philosophy,
if at all?
The parts of philosophy that
are closest to AI I think,
or at least the closest to AI
that I think about our stuff like
belief and knowledge and deportation and
that kind of stuff and that's, you know,
it's quite formal and it's like just
one step away from the kinds of computer
science work that we do kind of routinely.
I think that there are important questions
still about what you can do with a
machine and what you can't and so on.
Although at least my personal view is
that I'm completely a materialist and I
don't think that there's any reason why
we can't make a robot be behaviourally
indistinguishable from human.
And the question of whether
it's distinguishable internally,
whether it's a Zombie or not. In
philosophy terms, I actually don't,
I don't know and I don't know
if I care too much about that.
I would.
There is a philosophical notions,
they're mathematical and philosophical
because we don't know so much of how
difficult it is.
How difficult is it perception problem?
How difficult is the planning problem?
How difficult is it to operate
in this wall successfully?
Because our robots are not currently as
successful as human beings in many tasks.
The question about the gap between
current robots and human beings borders a
little bit on philosophy.
Uh, you know, the,
the expanse of knowledge that's required
to operate in this world and the
ability to a form common sense knowledge,
the ability to reason about uncertainty.
Much of the work you've been doing.
There's, there's open questions
there that uh, I dunno,
it required to activate a
certain big picture view.
To me that doesn't seem like a
philosophical gap at all. To me it's a,
there is a big technical
gap. Yes, huge technical gap,
but I don't see any reason why it's
more than a technical gap. Perfect.
So when you mentioned Ai,
you mentioned Sri and uh,
maybe can you describe to me when
you first fell in love with robotics,
the robots or inspired a which,
so you should maybe mention a
flaky or shaky, shaky, flaky.
And what, what was the robot that
first captured your imagination?
What's possible?
Right.
Well those are,
the first robot I worked with was like
shaky was there about that the Sri people
had built. But by the time,
I think when I arrived,
it was sitting in a corner
of somebodies office,
dripping hydraulic fluid into a pan.
Uh,
but it's iconic and really
everybody should read the
shaky Tucker report because
it has so many good ideas in it.
I mean they invented a star search and
symbolic planning and learning macro
operators.
They had a low level kind of configuration
space planning for the robot.
They had vision, they had all this,
the basic ideas of a ton of things.
Shaky have arms that,
what was the job? Cheeky.
Cheeky was a mobile robot,
but it could push objects and so it would
move things around which actually with
its self, with spot, with his base. Um,
so it could, but it, and they had
painted the base boards black.
Uh, so it used, it used vision
to localize itself in a map.
It detected objects. It could detect
objects that were surprising to it.
Uh,
it would plan and replan based on what
it saw it reasons about whether to look
and take pictures.
I mean it really had the basics of,
of so many of the things
that we think about now. Um,
how did it represent the space around it?
So it had representations that a bunch
of different levels of abstraction.
So it had I think a kind of an occupancy
grid of some sort at the lowest level.
Uh,
at the high level it was a abstract,
symbolic kind of rooms and
connectivity does flaky coming? Yeah.
Okay. So I should have, but Sri and the,
we were building a brand new robot.
As I said,
none of the people from
the previous project,
we're kind of there are involved anymore.
So we were kind of starting from scratch
and my advisor was standards and shine.
He ended up being my thesis advisor
and he was motivated by this idea of
situated computation
are situated automata.
And the idea was that the tools of
logical reasoning were important,
but possibly only for the engineers or
designers to use in the analysis of a
system, but not necessarily
to be manipulated in the
head of the system itself.
Right? So I might use logic to prove a
theorem about the behavior of my robot,
even if the robot's not using logic
and it's had to prove their upstream.
So that was kind of the distinction.
And so the idea was to kind of use those
principles to make a robot do stuff.
But a lot of the basic things we had to
kind of learn for ourselves because I
had zero background in robotics,
I didn't know anything about control.
I didn't know anything about sensors.
So we reinvented a lot of wheels on the
way to getting that robot to do stuff.
Do you think that was an advantage or
a hindrance? Oh No, it's, I mean, I,
I'm big in favor of wheel
reinvention actually everyone,
I think you learn a lot by doing it.
It's important though to eventually
have the pointers to so that you can see
what's really going on. But I think
you can appreciate much better the,
the good solutions once you've messed
around a little bit on your own and found
a bad one.
Yeah.
I think you've mentioned reinventing
reinforcement learning and referring to a
rewards as pleasures.
I have pleasure or I think,
which I think is a nice name for it.
It's more,
it's more fun to almost,
do you think you could
tell the history of AI,
machine learning,
reinforcement learning,
how you think about it
from the fifties to now?
One thing is that it's oscillates,
right?
So things become fashionable and then
they go out and then something else
becomes cool on that goes out and so on.
And I think there's,
so there's some interesting sociological
process that actually drives a lot of
what's going on.
Early days was kind of
cybernetics and control, right?
And the idea that of homeostasis.
People who've made these robots
that could, I don't know,
try to plug into the wall when they
needed power and then come loose and roll
around and do stuff.
And then I think over time the thought,
well,
that was inspiring, but
people said, no, no, no.
We want to get maybe closer to what
feels like real intelligence or human
intelligence.
And then maybe the expert
systems people tried to do that,
but maybe a little too
superficially. Right? So, oh,
we get this surface understanding of
what intelligence is like because I
understand how a steel mill works and I
can try to explain it to you and you can
write it down in logic and then we
can make a computer in for that.
And then that didn't work out.
But what's interesting,
I think is when the thing starts
to not be working very well.
It's not only do we change
methods, we change problems, right?
So it's not like we have better ways
of doing the problem with the expert
systems people were trying to do. We have
no ways of trying to do that problem.
Oh yeah. I know. I think maybe a few,
but we kind of give up on that problem
and we switched to a different problem
and we, we worked that for a while
and we make progress as a community.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people who would
argue you don't give up on the problem is
just the you a decrease the
number of people working on it.
You almost kind of like
put it on the shelf.
So we'll come back to this 20 years later.
Yeah, that's right. Or you might
decide that it's malformed.
Like you might say,
okay,
it's trying to just try to make
something that does superficial,
symbolic reasoning,
behave like a doctor.
You can't do that until you've had the
sensory motor experience of being a
doctor or something.
Right.
So there's arguments that say that
that's [inaudible] problem was not well
formed where it could be
that it is well formed, but,
but we just weren't approaching it.
Well,
you mentioned mentioned that your favorite
part of logic and symbolic systems is
that they give short names for large sets.
So there is some use to this.
Uh,
they use some symbolic
reasoning. So looking at expert
systems and symbolic computing,
where do you think are the roadblocks that
were hit in the eighties and nineties?
Ah, okay. So right.
So the fact that I'm not a fan of expert
systems doesn't mean that I'm not a fan
of some kinds of symbolic
reasoning. Right? So yeah,
let's see.
Roadblocks and well,
the main road block I think was that the
idea that humans could articulate their
knowledge effectively
into, into, you know,
some kind of logical statements.
So it's not just the cost, the effort,
but really just the capability of doing it
right. Because we're all
experts in vision, right? Yeah,
totally don't have introspective
access into how we do that. Right.
And it's true that,
I mean, I think the idea was, well of
course even if people then would know,
of course,
I wouldn't ask you to please write down
the rules that you use for recognizing
water bottle. That's crazy.
And everyone understood that.
But we might ask you to please write
down the rules you use for deciding,
I dunno what tie to put on or how to set
up a microphone or something like that.
But even those things,
I think people maybe,
I think what they found,
I'm not sure about this,
but I think what they found was that
the so called experts could give
explanations that sort of
post hoc explanations for
how and why they did things,
but they weren't necessarily
very good and then they differ.
They depended on maybe some
kinds of perceptual things,
which again, they couldn't really
define very well. So I think,
I think fundamentally I think that the
underlying problem with that was the
assumption that people could articulate
how and why they make their decisions.
Right. So it's almost I
encoding the knowledge, uh,
converting from experts is something
that a machine can understand and reason
with.
No, no, no, no. Not even just in coding,
but getting it out of you. Right.
Not, not, not writing
it down. I mean, yes,
hard also to write it
down for the computer,
but I don't think that
people can produce it.
You can tell me a story about why
you do stuff, but I'm not so sure.
That's the Y.
Great.
So there are still on the
hierarchical planning side
places where symbolic reasoning
is very useful. So, um, as,
as you've talked about,
so yeah,
where, where's the gap? Okay, good.
So saying that humans can't provide a
description of their reasoning processing
these, that's okay, fine.
But that doesn't mean that it's not
good to do reasoning of various styles
inside a computer.
Those are just two orthogonal points.
So then the question is what kind of
reasoning should you do inside a computer?
Right?
Uh,
and the answer is I think you need to do
all different kinds of reasoning inside
a computer depending on what
kinds of problems you face.
I guess the question is what kinds
of things can you encode Incode,
symbolic,
the seat can reason about,
I think the idea about an end,
even symbolic.
I don't even like that terminology
because they don't know what it means
technically. Informally. I
do believe in abstractions.
Abstractions are critical,
right?
You cannot reason at completely fine
grain about everything in your life,
right?
You can't make a plan at the level of
images and torques for getting a phd.
Right?
So you have to reduce the size of the
state space and you have to reduce the
horizon if you're going to reason
about getting a phd or even buying the
ingredients to make dinner.
And so,
so how can you reduce the spaces and the
horizon of the reasoning you have to do
and the answer's abstractions, spacial
extraction and temporal abstraction.
I think abstraction along the
lines of goals is also interesting.
Like you might or,
well,
abstraction in de composition goals is
maybe more of a decomposition thing.
So I think that's where these kinds of,
if you want to call it symbolic
or discrete models come in you,
you talk about a room of your house
instead of your pose. You talk about,
uh, you know, doing something during
the afternoon instead of at two 54.
And you do that because it makes you
reasoning problem easier. And also because
you have,
you don't have enough information to
reason in high fidelity about your pose of
your elbow at two 35 this afternoon
anyway. Right? When you try to get a phd,
you're doing anything except for
at that moment. At that moment,
you do have to reason about the
posterior elbow maybe, but then you,
maybe you do that and some continuous
joint space kind of model it. So again, I,
my biggest point about all of
this is that there should be,
the dogma is not the
thing, right? We shouldn't,
it shouldn't be that I am in favor or
against symbolic reasoning and you're in
favor against neural networks.
It should be that just,
just computer science tells us what the
right answer to all these questions is.
If we were smart enough to figure it out.
Yeah. When you tried to actually
solve the problem with computers,
the right answer comes out. Uh,
you mentioned abstractions. I mean,
you all know works form abstractions
or, uh, rather. Uh, there's,
there's automated ways to farm strategies
and there's expert driven waste to
forums tractions and a
expert human driven ways.
Humans just seems to be way better at
forming abstractions currently and certain
problems.
So when you're referring to
2:45 PM versus afternoon,
how do we construct that taxonomy?
Is there any room for automated
construction of such abstractions?
Oh, I think eventually, yeah. I mean,
I think when we get to be
better and machine learning,
engineers will build algorithms
that bill awesome extractions
that are useful in this kind of
way that you're describing. Yeah.
So let's then step from the,
the abstraction discussion and let's talk
about a bomb MDPs partially observable
mark decision prophecies.
So uncertainty.
So first watermark off decision procesees
what are America decision process and
maybe how much of our world can be
models and MDPs how much when you,
when you wake up in the morning,
he making breakfast, how do you,
do you think of yourself as an MDP?
So how do you think about a MDPs
and how they relate to our world?
Well, so there's a stance question, right?
So a stance is a position that I
take with respect to their problem.
So I as a researcher or a
person who designed systems
can decide to make a model
of the world around me in
some terms and the right.
So I take this messy world and I say
I'm going to treat it as if it were a
problem of this formal kind.
And then I can apply solution concepts
or algorithms or whatever to solve that
formal thing, right? So of
course the world is not anything,
it's not an MDP or a palm DP.
I don't know what it is,
but I can model aspects of it
in some way or some other way.
And when I model some aspect
of it in a certain way,
that gives me some set
of algorithms I can use.
You can model the world and all
kinds of ways. Yeah. Uh, some have,
some are more accepting of uncertainty,
more easily modeling
uncertainty of the world.
Some really forced the
world to be deterministic.
And so there's certainly MDPs, uh,
model the uncertainty of the world.
Yes. Model some uncertainty. They
model not present state uncertainty,
but they model uncertainty in the
way of the future will unfold, right?
Yep. So what are mark off
decision process? Okay,
so Margaret decision process as a model.
It's a kind of a model that
you could make that says,
I know completely the current state
of my system and what it means to be a
state. Is that I, that all the info,
I have all the information right now that
will let me make predictions about the
future as well as I can so
that remembering anything
about my history wouldn't
make my predictions any better. Um, and,
but,
but then it also says that then I can
take some actions that might change the
state of the world and that I don't have
a deterministic model of those changes.
I have a probabilistic model of
how the world might change. Uh,
it's a, it's a useful model for some
kinds of systems. I think it's a, I mean,
it's certainly not a good model
for most problems I think.
Because for most problems that you
don't actually know the state, uh,
for most problems you,
it's partially observed.
So that's now a different problem class.
So the,
okay,
that's where the poverty
piece of partially absorbed
Mako decision process step.
And so how do they address the
fact that you can't observe most,
uh, you have incomplete information
about most of the world around you,
right? So now the idea is we still kind
of postulate that there exists a state.
We think that there is some information
about the world out there such that if
we knew that we could make good
predictions but we don't know the state.
And so then we have to think about how,
but we do get observations.
Maybe I get images right here.
Things are I feel things and those
might be local or noisy and so therefore
they're going to tell me
everything about what's going on.
And then I have to reason about,
given the history of actions,
I've taken an observations, I've gotten,
what do I think is going on in the world?
And then given my own kind of uncertainty
about what's going on in the world,
I can decide what actions to take.
And so difficult is this
problem of planning under
uncertainty in your view and
you long experience of modeling the world,
trying to deal with this uncertainty
in suspicion, real wall systems,
dumb all planning for even discrete palm
dps can be undecidable depending on how
you set it up and for,
so lots of people say,
I don't use palm [inaudible]
because they are intractable.
And I think that that's our kind of
a very funny thing to say because the
problem you have to solve is
the problem you have to solve.
So if the problem you have
to solve as intractable,
that's what makes us AI
people, right? So, uh, we saw,
we understand that the
problem we're solving is,
is complete wildly
intractable that we can't,
we will never be able to solve it
optimally. At least I don't. Yeah. Right.
So later we can come back to an idea
about bounded optimality something.
But anyway, we can't come up with
optimal solutions to these problems.
So we have to make approximations,
approximations in modeling approximations
in solution algorithms and so on.
And so I don't have a problem with saying,
yeah,
my problem actually it is a palm DP
in continuous space with continuous
observations in, it's so computationally
complex. I can't even think about it's,
you know,
big or whatever.
But that doesn't prevent me from,
it helps me,
gives me some clarity to think about it
that way and to then take steps to make
approximation after approximation
to get down to something that's like
computable in some reasonable time.
When you think about optimality,
the community broadly is shifted on that
I think a little bit in how much they
value the idea of a optimality
of chasing an optimal solution.
How is of use of chasing
an optimal solution changed
over the years and when you
work with robots?
That's interesting.
I think we have a little bit of a meth
for the logic go crisis actually from the
theoretical side. I mean, I do think that
there is important in that right now.
We're not doing much of it.
So there's lots of empirical
hacking around and training
this and doing that and
reporting numbers. But
is it good? Is it bad?
We don't know if there's
very hard to say things.
And if you look,
uh,
like computer science theory,
so people talk for a while, everyone
was about solving problems optimally.
You're completely and, and then there
were interesting relaxations. Wait,
so people look at,
Oh,
can I are their regret bounds
or can I do some kind of,
um,
you know,
approximation can improve something that
I can approximately solve this problem
or that I get closer to the solution
as I spend more time and so on.
What's interesting,
I think is that we don't have good
approximate solution concepts for very
difficult problems. Right? I like
to, you know, I like to say that I,
I'm interested in doing a very
bad job of very big problems. Uh,
uh, right. So very big, very big problems.
I like to do that, but I would,
I wish I could say something.
I wish I had a,
I don't know,
some kind of a of a formal solution
concept that I could use to say,
oh, this, this algorithm actually
it gives me something like,
I know what I'm going to get.
I can do something other than
just run it and get out six seven.
The notion is still somewhere
deeply compelling to you. Hmm.
The notion that you can say you can
drop thing on the table says this,
that you can expect this, this
algorithm and gave me some good results.
I hope science will, I mean there's
engineering and there's science.
I think that they're not exactly the same.
And I think right now we're making
huge engineering like leaps and bounds.
So the engineering is running way
ahead of the science, which is cool.
And often how it goes,
right?
So we're making things and nobody
knows how and why they work roughly,
but we need to turn that into science
was some form. There's some room for
formalizing. We need to know what the
Bulls are. Why does this, why
or why does that not work?
I mean for awhile people
build bridges by trying,
but now we can often predict whether it's
going to work it out without building
it.
Can we do that
for learning?
Systems are for robots.
So your hope is from a materialistic
perspective, that intelligence,
artificial intelligence systems, robots,
a Chi. I would just fancier bridges,
belief space. What's the difference
between belief space in state space?
Who mentioned MDPS MDPs you reasoning,
uh,
about you sense the world. There's
a state, uh, w w what's this belief?
Space idea. Yeah. Okay.
That sounds good.
So I believe space that is,
instead of thinking about what's the
state of the world and trying to control
that as a robot,
I think about what is the space of
beliefs that I could have about the world.
What's,
if I think of a belief as a probability
distribution of her ways the world could
be a belief state is a distribution.
And then my control problem,
if I'm reasoning about how to move
through a world I'm uncertain about my
control problem is actually the
problem with controlling my beliefs.
So I think about taking actions,
not just what effect they'll
have on the world outside,
but what effect I'll have on my own
understanding of the world outside.
And so that might compel me to ask a
question or look somewhere together,
information, which may not
really change the world state,
but it changes my own
belief about the world.
That's a powerful way to,
to empower the agent to
reason about the world,
explore the world to what kind of
problems does that allow you to solve, to,
to uh, consider belief space
versus just stay space?
Well, any problem that requires
deliberate information gathering, right?
So if in some problems,
okay,
like chess,
there's no uncertainty or maybe
there's uncertainty about the opponent.
There's no uncertainty about the
state. Uh, and some problems,
there's uncertainty, but you
gather information as you
go, right? You might say, Oh,
I'm driving my autonomous car down the
road and it doesn't know perfectly where
it is, but the lidars are
all going on at the time.
So I don't have to think about
whether to gather information.
But if you're a human
driving down the road,
you sometimes look over your shoulder
to see what's going on behind you in the
lane and you have to decide whether you
should do that now and you have to trade
off the fact that you're not seeing in
front of you when you're looking behind
you. And how valuable is
that information and so on.
And so to make choices about information
gathering, you have to reasonably space
also also,
I mean also too just take into account
your uncertainty before trying to do
things.
So you might say,
if I understand where I'm
standing relative to the door jam,
uh, pretty accurately, then it's
okay for me to go through the door.
But if I'm really not
sure where the door is,
then it might be better to not do that.
Right now.
The degree of your uncertainty ball
about the world is actually part of the
thing you're trying to
optimize, informing, forming
the plan. Right. Gotcha.
So this idea of a long horizon of a
planning for a phd or just even how to get
out of the house or how
to make breakfast here,
that you show this presentation of the,
the WTF or is the fork of
robot looking at the sink?
Uh,
and uh,
can you describe how we plan in this
world is idea of hierarchical planning?
We've mentioned this, this is, yeah.
How can a robot hope to plan
about something? Uh, oh,
this was such a long horizon
where the goal is quite far away.
People since probably reasoning began
how thought about hierarchical reasoning,
the temporal hierarchy and predict,
well, their spacial hierarchy.
But let's talk about temporal
hierarchy. So you might say,
oh, I have this long, uh,
execution I have to do,
but I can divide it into some
segments abstractly, right?
So maybe you have to get out of the house.
I have to get in the car,
I have to drive and so on.
And so you can plan if you can
build abstractions. So this,
we started out by talking about
abstractions and we're back to that now.
If you can build abstractions in
your state space and abstractions,
sort of temporal abstractions,
then you can make plans at a
high level and you can say,
I'm going to go to town and then I'll
have to get gas and then I can go here and
I can do this other thing and you
can reason about the dependencies and
constraints among these actions.
Again,
without thinking about
the complete details,
what we do in our hierarchical
planning work is then say, all right,
I make a plan at a high
level of abstraction.
I have to have some reason to think that
it's feasible without working it out in
complete detail and that's
actually the interesting step.
I always liked to talk about
walking through an airport,
like you can plan to go to New York
and arrive at the airport and then find
yourself in a office building later.
You can't even tell me in advance what
your plan is for walking through the
airport. Partly because you're
too lazy to think about it maybe,
but partly also because you
just don't have the information.
You don't know what get your landing in
or what people are going to be in front
of you or anything.
So there's no point in planning in detail,
but you have to have,
you have to make a leap of faith that
you can figure it out once you get there.
And it's really interesting
to me how you arrive at that.
How do you say you have learned over your
lifetime to be able to make some kinds
of predictions about how hard it is
to achieve some kinds of sub goals.
And that's critical. Like you would never
plan to fly somewhere if you couldn't,
didn't have a model of how hard it was
to do some of the intermediate steps.
So one of the things we're thinking about
now is how do you do this kind of very
aggressive generalization,
uh,
we to situations that you haven't been
in it and so on to predict how long will
it take to walk through the Kuala Lumpur
airport like you can you give me an
estimate and it wouldn't be crazy.
And you have to have an estimate of
that in order to make plans that involve
walking through the qual on port airport,
even if you don't need
to know it in detail.
So I really interested in these kinds
of abstract models and how do we acquire
them, but once we have them, we can use
them to do hierarchical reasoning is,
I think it's very important.
Yeah.
There's this notion of go a
goal regression and pretty
image back chaining this
idea of starting at the
goal and it's just for me,
big clouds of states you get,
I mean it's almost like saying to
the airport, you know, you know,
once you show up to the,
uh, the airport did,
that's you, you're like a
few steps away from the goal.
So like thinking of it this way,
uh, it's kind of interesting.
I don't know if you have sort of
a further comments on that, uh,
of starting at the goal,
right?
Yeah. I mean, it's interesting
that Simon Herb Simon,
back in the early days,
the way I talked a lot about means ends
reasoning and reasoning back from the
goal. There's a kind of an
intuition that people have that
the number of state space is big.
The number of actions you could
take is really big. So if you say,
here I sit and I want to
search forward from where I am,
what are all the things I could do
that's just overwhelming. If you say,
if you can reason at this other level and
say, here's what I'm hoping to achieve,
what can I do to make that true?
That somehow the branching is smaller.
Now what's interesting is that like in
the AI planning community that hasn't
worked out in the class of problems,
that they look at it and the
methods that they tend to use it,
how's it turned out that it's
better to go backward? Um,
it's still kind of my
intuition that it is,
but I can't prove that to you right now.
Right?
Tuition, at least for
us mere humans. Uh Huh.
Speaking of which, uh, when you, uh,
maybe I would take it and take a look,
take a little step into that philosophy
circle. Uh, how hard would it,
when you think about human life,
you should give those examples often.
How hard do you think it is to formulate
human life supplanting problem or
aspects of human life?
So when you look at robots,
you're often trying to think about
object manipulation tasks about moving a
thing.
When you,
when you take a slight
step outside the room,
let the robot leave and go get
lunch, uh, or maybe tried to uh,
pursue more fuzzy goals,
how hard do you think is that problem?
If you were to try to maybe put another
way, try to formulate a human life as,
as a planning problem?
Well that would be a mistake. I mean
it's not all the planning problem, right?
Every,
I think it's really,
really important that we understand
that you have to put together pieces and
parts that have different styles of
reasoning and representation and learning.
I think. I think it's, it's, it
seems probably clear to anybody that,
that it,
it can't all be this or all be that
brains aren't all like this are all like
that, right? They have different pieces
and parts and substructure. And so on.
So I don't think that there's any good
reason to think that there's going to be
like when true algorithmic thing
that's going to do the whole job,
it's just a bunch of pieces together,
uh,
designed to solve a bunch
of specific problem.
One specific styles of problems.
I mean there's probably some reasoning
that needs to go on in image space.
I think again,
there's this model based
versus model free idea, right?
So in reinforcement learning, people
talk about, oh, should I learn,
I could learn a policy just
straight up a way of behaving.
I could learn it's popular,
only a value function and that's some
kind of weird intermediate ground, uh,
or I could learn a transition model
or it's tells me something about the
dynamics of the world.
If I take a train,
if I imagine that I learned
in a transition model and
I couple it with a planner
and I draw a box around
that, I have a policy. Again,
it's just stored in a
different way. Right? Right.
It's an but it's just as much
of a policy is the other policy.
It's just I've made,
I think the way I see it is it's a
timespace tradeoff in computation,
right? At more overt policy
representation. Maybe it takes more space,
but maybe I can compute quickly what
action I should take. On the other hand,
maybe a very compact model of the
world dynamics plus a planner.
Let's make compute what action to take
to just more slowly. There's no, I don't,
I mean I don't think there's
no argument to be had.
It's just like a question of what form
of computation is best for us for the
various sub problems.
Right.
So and and so like learning to do Algebra
and manipulations for some reason is,
I mean that's probably going to
want naturally a sort of a different
representation then riding
a unicycle at the time.
Constraints on the unicycle or serious
this thing. Spaces maybe smaller,
I don't know.
But so I
be the more human sides
of falling in love.
Having a relationship
that might be another
Ah, yeah. Good. Another style up. No
how to model that.
Yeah.
That was first to solve the Algebra
and object manipulation. Yeah.
What do you think is harder?
Perception or planning?
Perception. That's why
understanding, that's fine. Uh,
so what do you think is so hard about
perception by understanding the world
around you?
Well, I mean, I think the big question
is representational. A hugely,
the question is representation.
So perception that has
made great strides lately,
right in the weekend.
Classify images and we can
okay.
Play certain kinds of games and predict
how to steer the car and all that sort
of stuff.
Um,
I don't think we have a very good idea
of what perception should deliver.
Right? So if you, if you believe
in modularity, okay, there's,
there's a very strong view which says
we build in any modularity.
We should make a giant Jag,
can't take neural network training
end to end to do the thing.
And that's the best way forward.
And it's hard to argue with that
except on a sample complexity basis,
right? So you might say, oh,
well if I wanted to do end to end
reinforcement learning on this giant,
giant neural network,
it's going to take a lot of data and
a lot of like broken robots and stuff.
So,
yeah.
Then the only answer is to say,
okay,
we have to build something in
building some structure or some bias.
We know from theory of machine learning,
the only way to cut down in the sample
complexity is to kind of cut down somehow
cut down the hypothesis space.
You can do that by building in bias.
There's all kinds of reason to think
that nature built bias into humans. Um,
convolution is a bias,
right?
It's a very strong bias and
is a very critical bias.
So my own view is that we should look for
more things that are like convolution,
but the address, other
aspects of reasoning, right?
So convolution helps us a lot with a
certain kind of spatial reasoning that's
quite close to the imaging.
I think there's other ideas like that,
maybe some amount of forward search,
maybe some notions of abstraction,
maybe the notion that objects exist.
Actually,
I think that's pretty important in a lot
of people won't give you that to start
with almost like a
convolution in the, uh, uh,
uh, in the object semantic objects,
spaces, some kind, some kind of,
some kind of idea.
That's right.
And people just started like the graph
graph convolutions or an idea that are
related to racial
relational representations.
And so I think there are,
so you,
I've come far afield from
perception, but I think, um,
I think the thing that's going to make
perception that kind of the next step is
actually understanding better
what it should produce, right?
So what are we going to do
with the output of it? Right?
It's fine when what we're going
to do with the output is steer.
It's less clear when we're just trying
to make one integrated intelligent agent.
What should the output of perception be?
We have no idea.
And how should that hook up to the
other stuff we don't know? Right?
So I think the pressing question is what
kinds of structure can we build in that
are like the moral equivalent
of convolution that will
make a really awesome
superstructure that then learning
can kind of progress on efficiently?
I agree.
Very compelling description of actually
where we stand with the perception of
them. You're teaching a course
and embodied intelligence.
What do you think it takes to build a
robot with human level intelligence?
I don't know if we knew we would do it
if you were to, I mean, okay, so do
you think a robot and used to have a,
a self awareness,
a consciousness and fear
of mortality or is it,
is it simpler than that or
is consciousness a simple
thing they [inaudible] do
you think about these notions?
I don't think much about it.
Consciousness,
even most philosophers who care
about it will give you that.
You could have robots that are zombies,
right?
That behave like humans but they're not
conscious and I at this moment we'd be
happy enough for that. So I'm not
really worried one way or the other.
So the technical side, you're not
thinking of the use of self awareness.
Okay.
But then what is self awareness mean?
I mean that you need to have some part
of the system that can observe other
parts of the system and tell
whether they're working well or not.
That seems critical.
So does that count this,
I mean does that kind of
self awareness or not? Well,
it depends on whether you
think that there's somebody
at home who can articulate
whether they're self aware, but
clearly if I have like, you know,
some piece of code that's counting how
many times this procedure gets executed.
That's a kind of self awareness.
Right? So there's a big spectrum.
It's clear you have to have some of it.
Right.
You know, we're quite far
away, I many dimensions,
but is a direction of research
that's most compelling to you for,
you know,
tried to achieve human level intelligence
and our robots? Well, to me,
I guess the thing that seems most
compelling to me at the moment is this
question of what to build in
and want to learn. Um, I think,
yeah,
we're, we don't, we're
missing a bunch of ideas and,
and we, you know, people, you know,
don't you dare ask me how many years
it's going to be till that happens.
Cause I won't even participate in the
conversation because I think we're missing
ideas and I don't know how long
it's going to take to find them.
So I won't ask you how many years,
but, uh, maybe I'll ask you.
Yeah.
Would it
when you will be sufficiently impressed
that we've achieved it. So what's,
what's a a good test of intelligence?
Do you like the Turing test and
natural language and the robotic space?
Is there something, wait, you
would sit back and think, oh,
us as pretty impressive, uh,
as a test, as a benchmark.
Do you think about
these kinds of problems?
No, I resist. I mean,
I think all the time that we spend arguing
about those kinds of things could be
better spent just making
the robots work better,
you know, value competition. So I mean
there's the nature of benchmark, uh,
benchmarks and datasets or touring test
challenges where everybody kind of gets
together and tries to build a better robot
because they want to out compete each
other. I the Darpa challenge
with the autonomous vehicles,
do you see the value of that
or it can get in the way? I think
it can get in the way. I mean,
there's some people, many people find
it motivating and so that's good.
I find it anti motivating personally.
Yeah. Uh, but I think what,
I mean,
I think you'd get an interesting cycle
where for a contest or a bunch of smart
people get super motivated and they hacked
the brains out and much of what gets
done is just hacks.
But sometimes really cool ideas emerge
and then that gives us something to chew
on after that. So I'm, I, it's
not a thing for me, but I don't,
I don't regret that other people do it.
Yeah.
And like you said with everything
else to the mix is good.
So jumping topics a little bit,
he started the journal and
machine learning research
and served as its editor in
chief. Uh, how did the
publication come about?
Hmm.
And uh,
what do you think about the
current publishing model
space in a machine learning
or artificial intelligence?
Okay, good. So it came about because there
was a journal called machine learning.
We're still exists,
which was own by Kluwer.
And there was,
I was on the editorial board and we used
to have these meetings and really where
we were to complain to Kluwer that it
was too expensive for the libraries on
that people couldn't publish and we
would really like to have some kind of
relief on those friends and they would
always sympathize but not doing anything.
So, uh, I just decided to
make a new journal. And, uh,
there was the journal of Ai Research,
which has, was on the same model,
which had been in existence
for maybe five years or so.
And it was going along
pretty well. So, uh,
we just made a new journal. It
wasn't, I mean, it, um, I don't know,
I guess it was work, but it wasn't that
hard. So basically the editorial board,
probably 75% of the editorial board
of a machine learning resigned and we
founded the new, this new
journal. But it was sort of,
there's more open. Yeah.
Right. So it's completely open.
It's open access. Actually.
Uh, uh, I had a postdoc,
George kind of Doris,
we wanted to call these journals
free for all because there were,
I mean,
it both has no page charges and has no,
uh,
access restrictions and the reason
and so lots of people, I mean,
there were,
there were people who were mad about the
existence of this journal who thought
it was a fraud or something.
It would be impossible.
They said to run a journal like
this with basically, I mean,
for a long time I didn't
even have a bank account. Uh,
I paid for the lawyer to incorporate and
the Ip address and just due to cost a
couple hundred dollars a year to run.
It's a little bit more now,
but not that much more.
But that's because I think
computer scientists are
competent and autonomous in a
way that many scientists and other fields
aren't doing these kinds of things.
We already type set around papers.
We all have students and people who can
hack a website together in the afternoon.
So the infrastructure us
was like not a problem,
but for other people in other fields,
it's a harder thing to do.
Yeah. And this kind of open access
journal and nevertheless one of the most
prestigious journals.
So it's not like a prestige and it can
be achieved without any of the companies
are required. Yeah. For
Prestige. Yeah. Turns out. Yeah.
So on the review process side
of actually a long time ago,
I don't remember when I reviewed a paper
where you were also a reviewer and I
remember reading your view
of being influenced by it.
It was really well written.
It did influence how I write
feature reviews. Uh, you
disagreed with me actually,
uh, you made it, uh, my review,
but much better. So, but
nevertheless, the review process,
you know, has its flaws.
And how do you think,
what do you think works well?
How can it be improved?
So actually when I started
jam are I wanted to do
something completely different
and I didn't because it felt like we
needed a traditional journal of record.
And so we just made jam our be almost
like a normal journal except for the open
access parts of it
basically. Um, increasingly,
of course publication is
not even a sensible word.
You can publish something about
putting it in an archive for.
So I can publish everything tomorrow.
So making stuff public is,
there's no barrier.
We still need curation and evaluation.
I don't have time to read all of archive.
And you could argue that
kind of social thumbs
upping of articles suffices,
right? You might say, Oh heck with
this we don't need journalists and all,
we'll put everything on archive and people
will upload and download the articles
and then your CV, we'll say, oh
man, they, he got a lot of boats.
So that's good.
Um,
but I think there's still
cool
value in careful reading
and commentary of things.
And it's hard to tell when people aren't
voting and down voting or arguing about
your paper on Twitter and Reddit,
whether they know what
they're talking about. Right.
So then I have the second order problem
of trying to decide whose opinions I
should value and such. So, I dunno,
I W W if I had infinite time,
which I don't,
and I'm not going to do this because
I really want to make the robots work.
But if I felt inclined to do something
more than a publication direction,
I would do this other thing which I
thought about doing the first time,
which is to get together some set of
people whose opinions I value and who were
pretty articulate. And I guess we would
be public, although it could be private,
I'm not sure.
And we would review papers,
we wouldn't publish them and
you wouldn't submit that.
We were just fine papers and we would
write reviews and we would make those
reviews public. And
maybe if you, you know,
so we're Leslie's friends who review
papers and maybe eventually if we,
our opinion was sufficiently valued,
like the opinion of jam ours valued,
then you'd say on your CV that Leslie's
friends gave my paper of five star
rating and that would be just as
good as saying, I got it, you know,
accepted into this
journal. Um, so I think,
I think we should have
good public commentary, uh,
and organize it in some way,
but I don't really know how to do it.
It's interesting times
the way the, the way you describe
it actually is really interesting.
Then he would do it for movies.
I am db.com there's a experts,
critics come in, they write reviews,
but there's also regular non critics.
Humans write reviews and
they're separated. Open Review.
Well the,
the,
the I I clear process
I think is interesting.
It's a step in the right direction, but
it's still not as compelling as a, uh,
reviewing movies or video games.
I mean it sometimes,
I'll almost as, it might be silly
as least from my perspective to say,
but it boils down to the user interface,
how fun and easy it is to actually
perform the reviews. How efficient,
how much you as a reviewer get a
street cred for being a good reviewer.
Those elements,
those human elements come into play.
No, it's a big investment to
do a good review or a paper.
And the flood of papers is that
control. Right. So, you know,
there aren't 3000 new, I don't know how
many new movies are there in a year.
I don't know.
But that's probably going to be less
than how many machine learning papers are
in a year now. And I'm
worried. I, you know, I,
I uh, right, so I'm like an old person,
so of course I'm going to say Rar, Rar,
rar and things are moving too fast.
I'm a stick in the mud.
Uh, so I can say that,
but my particular flavor of that is I
think the horizon for researchers has
gotten very short that students want to
publish a lot of papers and there's a
huge,
there's value,
it's exciting and there's value in that
and you get patted on the head for it
and so on. But, and some of that is fine,
but I'm worried that we're driving out
people who would spend two years thinking
about something.
Back in my day when we worked on our
theses, we did not publish papers.
You did your thesis for years, you pick
the hard problem and then you worked in,
chewed on it and did stuff and
waste of time for a long time.
And when it was roughly when it was done,
you would write papers.
And so I don't know how to answer and I
don't think that everybody has to work
in that mode,
but I think there's some problems that
are hard enough that it's important to
have a longer her research horizon.
And I'm worried though we don't
incentivize that at all. At this point
in this current structure,
what do you see as a,
what are your hopes and fears about the
future of AI and continue on this theme?
So Ai has gone through a few winters,
ups and downs.
Do you see another winter of AI coming,
uh,
or do you more hopeful
about making robots work?
As he said,
I think the cycles are inevitable,
but I think each time we get
higher, right. I mean, so, you know,
it's like climbing some kind
of landscape within noisy, uh,
optimizer. Yeah. So it's
clear that the, the,
you know,
the deep learning stuff has made
deep and important improvements.
And so the high water mark is now
higher. I, there's no question,
but of course I think people
are overselling and eventually,
uh, investors I guess, and other
people look around and say,
well,
you're not quite delivering on this
grand claim and that wild hypothesis it,
so probably it's going to crash some
of them out. And then it's okay.
I mean it,
but I don't,
I can't imagine that there's like some
awesome monotonic improvement from here
to human level Ai. So in, uh, you know,
I have to ask this question, I'd probably
anticipate answers the answers, but, uh,
do you have a worry short term or long
term about the existential threats of Ai
and
maybe short term,
less existential but more
a robot's taking away jobs?
Hmm. Well, actually,
let me talk a little bit about utility.
Actually,
I had an interesting conversation with
some military ethicists who wanted to
talk to me about autonomous weapons.
And there they were interesting,
smart,
well educated guys who didn't know
too much about AI or machine learning.
And the first question they asked me was,
has your robot ever done
something you didn't expect?
And I like burst out laughing because
anybody who's ever done something other
robot right knows that they don't do it.
And what I realized was that their
model of how we program a robot was
completely wrong.
Their model of how we can put program
robot was like Lego Mindstorms.
Like oh go for it, meet her, turn
left, take a picture, do this, do that.
And so if you have that model
of programming, then it's true.
It's kind of weird that you run what
would do something that you didn't
anticipate. But the fact
is, and and actually,
so now this is my new educational mission.
If I have to talk to non experts,
I tried to teach them the,
that we don't operate,
we operate at least one or maybe many
levels of abstraction about that.
And we say, Oh, here's a hypothesis class.
Maybe it's a space of plans or maybe
it's a space of classifiers or whenever.
But there's some set of answers
and the objective function.
And then we work on some optimization
method that tries to optimize a solution,
a solution in that class. And we don't
know what solution is going to come out.
Right. So I think it's
important to communicate that.
So I'm going of course probably people
who are listening to this, they,
they know that lesson.
But I think it's really critical
to communicate that lesson.
And then lots of people are
now talking about, you know,
the value alignment problem.
So you want to be sure as robots or
software systems get more competent that
their objectives are aligned
with your objectives or that, uh,
our objectives are compatible on some
way or we have a good way of mediating
when they have different objectives.
And so I think it is important
to start thinking in terms like,
you don't have to be freaked out by the
robot apocalypse to accept that it's
important to think about objective
functions of value alignment. Yes.
And that you have to really,
everyone who's done optimization knows
that you have to be careful what you wish
for that are, you know, sometimes you'd
get the optimal solution and you realize,
man, that was, that objective was wrong.
So pragmatically in the shortest term,
it seems to me that that those are really
interesting and critical questions.
And the idea that we're going to go from
being people who engineer algorithms to
being people who engineer objective
functions. I think that's,
that's definitely going to happen.
And that's going to change our
thinking and methodology and stuff.
You started at Stanford a philosophy
that's where she could go back to
philosophy maybe. Well, signing up there,
I mean they're mixed together because,
because as we also know as
machine learning people,
right? When you're designing,
in fact,
this is the lecture I gave in class today,
when you design an objective function,
you have to wear both hats.
There's the hat that says, what do I
want? And there's the hat that says, ah,
but I know what my optimizer can do to
some degree and I have to take that into
account. All right. So it's,
it's always a trade off and we
have to kind of be mindful of that.
The part about taking people's jobs,
I understand that that's important.
I don't understand sociology or
economics or people very well.
So I don't know how to think about that.
So that's, yeah, so there might
be a sociological aspect there.
The economic aspect that's very
difficult to think about it. Okay.
I mean I think other people should
be thinking about it, but I'm just,
that's not my strength.
So
what do you think is the most exciting
area of research in the short term for
the community and for you?
For Yourself?
Well,
so I mean there's the story I've been
telling you about how to engineer
intelligent robots. So that's what we want
to do. We all kind of want to do well,
I mean,
some set of us want to do this and the
question is what's the most effective
strategy?
And we've tried and there's a bunch of
different things you could do at the
extremes,
right?
One super extreme is we do introspection
and then we write a program. Okay.
That has not worked out really well.
Another extreme is we'd take a giant bunch
of neural guru and we try to train it
up to do something.
I don't think that's going to work either.
So the question is what's
the middle ground? And again,
this isn't a a theological
question or anything like that.
It's just like how do just, how do we,
what's the best way to make this work out?
And I think it's, it's clear, it's a
combination of learning. To me it's clear,
it's a combination of learning and not
learning and what should that combination
B and what's the stuff we build in. So to
me that's the most compelling question.
And when you say engineer robots,
you mean engineering systems that
work in the real world? Is that,
that's the emphasis.
The last question,
which robots? A robot is your
favorite from science fiction.
So you can go with star wars are our Rtg
d two or you can go with a more modern,
uh,
maybe how firm,
I don't think I have a favorite
robot from science fiction. This is,
this is back to you.
You like to make robots work in
the real world here? Not a, not an,
I mean, I love the process. I
care more about the process.
Yeah. I mean, I do
research because it's fun.
Not because I care about what
we produce. Well, that's a,
that's a beautiful note actually to,
and unless they,
thank you so much for talking
today. Sure. It's been fun.